criticism of Lancashire police over the
last three weeks is any of it valid
um I'm not sure it is you know and you
are seeing quite a number of people
um you know a police expertise retired
officers coming out raising concerns
about some of that politicism that it
seems to me that they did very Vigilant
inquiries around the local CCTV
um they had great support from local
people and from that we're able to trace
all the local witnesses that have seen
Nicola and fellow dog walkers
um and they also did extensive mobile
phone pricing that actually meant they
were able to narrow down the
circumstances in which it appeared that
Nicola had disappeared
um but then the problem with that is
that they then didn't have a lot more
information to give to the press in
terms of further leads or further
inquiries perhaps vehicles or people
they needed to trace because they had
been able to narrow things down in this
particular way
um so you know I think a lot of the
criticism has not been Justified and
it's really not in the public interest
when officers apply to investigate the
case like this but every detail is
poured over
um you know we've had all the influence
of social media people coming into the
area in the end the priest said get
dispersal order to remove some of those
people so I think the police have been
under huge pressure but from everything
I see you know they've tried to carry
out those inquiries in the methodical
way but they're with a quite
extraordinary level of press and public
interest which to some degree is
understandable but on the other hand
will be enormously frustrating to many
many other families who've lost loved
ones so saying why do we not get this
level of coverage and interest
so Peter the police have always said
right from the first news conference
that they thought that she was in the
water they continued to say throughout
that as far as they were concerned their
working hypothesis was that she was in
the water in other words that she was no
longer with us why on Earth did they
release information about her struggling
with the menopause and having a problem
with alcohol when they thought that she
was no longer with us
well so you know that's something that
they will have to justify I would point
out that you know whoever sadly this
body turns out to be there will be an
inquesting Quest heard in public uh and
often an inquest uh extreme you know
huge amounts of personal detail uh are
released about a person's personal
medical mental health um you know
background
um you know at the end of the day
Relationship police are accountable to
the police and crime commissioner
elected by the people of Lancashire
um and and they will be held to account
by that person but I think the fact is
they run to huge pressure
um you know and yes you can question
whether that was right or not but as I
say would point out in many many
inquiries investigations many personal
details have to be released uh they
feature in the criminal Pride if there
is going to be a trial and certainly an
inquest because all those are public
hearings
yeah but if it was important information
why didn't they release it initially
I don't know you know that that's for
them you know the trouble you know they
face is not really for them I'm asking
you sorry sir Peter no I'm asking you
and you are defending the actions of a
neighboring force and I understand why
you're doing that and I'm just putting
to you that This Woman's reputation has
been trashed and the police thought that
she was already dead
no I don't think you know that yes they
believe that the most likely outcome was
that she was already dead because of all
the inquiries that they had made
um and they felt it was in in the
interest in the public interest
interesting investigation to release
that information I don't know it was
right or wrong I you know was not there
in the investigation as I say there's a
very strong system of accountability
that they will have to be answerable too
and the ultimate judge of this really is
the family of of Port Nicola and the
police doing everything that they can to
try and obviously to get some form of
resolution to them but overall I think
the level of criticism has been
completely you know unjustified and
unbalanced at least a lot of officers
feeling uh disillusioned and as I say
there's a wider issue here about when
officers are under this degree of press
interest but public but particularly all
the issues on social media which I know
are very difficult to counter it just
makes that investigation much more
difficult and yes that will have to be
reflected upon by officers and by
Lancashire police as to whether there's
anything that they could have done
differently
the reason that there's been so much
interest is that it was a young mum of
two who went for a walk with her little
dog she disappeared at a Beauty Spot and
she was missing for three weeks we were
told that the river had been searched
and searched and searched again a body's
been found less than a mile away from
where she entered the water according to
the police
yeah and anybody that knows anything
about rivers and tidal flows and how
bodies um behave when they enter a water
um you know we'll know this is extremely
complex and difficult in trying to you
know search that you know I come back to
it you know everything I see is the
police so the Lancashire police have
been very Vigilant in all their
inquiries they've had great local
support
um you know I've never seen a case which
is that that degree of uh of Interest
yes there was some element of it being a
sort of like a mystery people say well
she disappeared off the face of the
earth I think Lancashire police from an
early stage looking at all the different
information they had had this particular
hypotheses they always stress that they
were trying to keep an open mind but the
difficulty they had was there was this
degree of public interest press interest
and at the end of the day they didn't
really have a lot more to say
um sadly they had to wait you know for
for the search and and for the body uh
to to be found
um and as but as I say that has been
frustrating them for the press and and
and for the public
and you don't so you don't feel from
what you're saying that criticisms by
the Home Secretary and also by the Prime
Minister who says that this pause has
questions to answer are valid
you know well I think you know they've
expressed concerns I don't think they've
criticize the police and and I think the
fact is they don't know all the details
of the investigation it is highly
unusual for National politicians to
intervene in a case like this as I say
the person the police are accountable at
the local level is the police and crime
commissioner and I'm sure their office
will look into this very closely
um but again you know on the other hand
I think there will be lots of other
families out there today who'll say Well
Mr Prime Minister can you please show
the same level of interest in in my case
because sadly every day there are
hundreds of people who go missing many
many are found by the police but there
are many families out there who sadly
are going through the agony every single
day
who said the
um Home Secretary wasn't critical she
said she was concerned and she wanted
answers
yes it was fine but you know and she can
say that and I'm sure Lancashire police
will express it will give those answers
but I'd still say it is very unusual for
a Home Secretary to get involved in a
live police investigation okay because
of the level of press and public
interest you felt she had to do that I'm
just pointing out that there is a very
strong accountability mechanism for the
police through the elected peace and
crime commissioner as well as a whole
body of expertise that the police follow
they will look at this case they will
review this case they will see what
learning that will be passed on to other
detectives around the country because I
say the police build all this on huge
amount of experience and expertise all
the officers involved have had to be
highly trained and accredited uh and you
know everything I've seen as I've tried
to do their best in this very difficult
case